yeah well Brian Denise what we see on
the screen every year of course is the
game the fans the halftime performance
of course but what about all the things
we don't see the barricades the
transportation to the stadium printing
the giant posters even the porta potties
outside the stadium those are all
services and goods that the NFL is
looking to local businesses to get for
next year's game and they're
specifically looking to minority owned
businesses
we're actually the only Funnel Cake Cafe
here in Las Vegas dinette bro serves up
funnel cake creations at Town Square
she's about to celebrate 17 years in the
valley and for the next anniversary
she's hoping to be serving here lighting
power things like that and Taisha Moore
is hoping 13 years of electrical
business in the Valley can be used
during Super Bowl 58. congratulations on
making it to this step let's talk about
where we go from here they join hundreds
of other Las Vegas businesses hoping to
subcontract for the biggest media event
in the world and if not the game itself
the tailgate VIP parties or other events
that lead up to it how they're chosen
the NFL business connect program
everyone will get an opportunity to
become more competitive B.J Weimer is
the program lead looking to connect
local business owners with the league we
want to be able to create opportunities
for everyone in the marketplace not just
someone who has a huge company and
everybody knows them but not just any
business those prepared for the
magnitude of demand the game brings and
who meet the program's vision of at
least 51 percent ownership by a woman
disabled person veteran lgbtq plus
member or racial minority seeing if they
don't get a contract with Super Bowl and
we're going to use that database and
that Reese those people's resources for
events that we have here with the
Raiders it gives Bros Funnel Cake Cafe
so much more exposure not just for the
Super Bowl but I like the fact that it
carries over those opportunities create
hope and and just the ability for us to
know that we can be part of something
that's bigger than what we've done in
the past
now what's in the program entrepreneurs
they go through seven months of
different workshops to meet their online
image with the NFL standards and just to
clarify these businesses they were all
referred to the NFL from local business
groups here in the valley the officials
for this business program they add
they're not clear about how many
contracts will be awarded but they say
with literally the world's largest
television event they say there's no
shortage of opportunities heading their
way reporting live outside Allegiant
Stadium Ryan Matthey a news now